cain la parole est à monsieur franck
gaillard ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre internet envers
monsieur le ministre les affres de la
guerre civile syrienne appelle des
solutions urgentes et concrètes tant
humanitaire que militaire la diplomatie
chacun le sait est l'art de concilier
l'inconciliable
les efforts se font sentir jusqu'en
europe avec les images spectaculaires de
migrants syriens ou non forçant par
dizaines de milliers les frontières de
notre continent
cependant on peut s'interroger sur
l'instrumentalisation de ces migrants à
la suite des déclarations et des
ambiguïtés des autorités turques
celles ci ont entretenu des rapports
s'équivaut qu'avec l'état islamique fai
de trafic toléré et de collaborations
diverses dictée par une commune
détestation du régime de bachar el-assad
les preuves sont multiples et le régime
de monsieur andorrane emprisonnent les
journalistes qui en parle
taylor pouvons-nous vraiment faire
confiance à monsieur erdogan pour
s'engager dans la lutte contre des ch
la turquie se propose entretenir deux
millions de réfugiés syriens contre 3
milliards d'euros versés par l'union
européenne bruxelles s'engagerait à
exempter le film de visa les 76 millions
de citoyens tueur de notre espace
schengen alors que celui ci abrite je
vous le rappelle plus le 3 millions 600
mille citoyens turcs ou binationaux
ce qui était pratiquement le double de
la vague migratoire dont nous sommes
menacés
enfin le premier ministre turc ahmet
davutoglu a déclaré nous allons forer la
destinée du continent européen
monsieur le ministre est il exact que
nous allons reprendre les négociations
avec la turquie pour baliser son entrée
au sein d'union malgré une opposition
très forte des opinions publiques
d'autre part quelle est la position du
gouvernement français sur cette
importante question je vaux bercy merci
monsieur gillard la parole à monsieur le
premier ministre